pendant près de vingt ans j'ai dû passé
la moitié de ma vie sur l'eau embarquée
relativement tôt dans la voile de
compétition et lui ensuite l'équipe
nationale les puits séries olympiques
puis course au large
et puis en fait qui est intéressant
c'est que je n'avais aucun intérêt pour
la croisière seule la compétition
comptait parce que je me la représentait
comme c'est un stand équilibre
extérieurement privilégié où tout l'art
consiste à ne rien faire a laissé faire
et a lâché prise
devant l'énormité de cet environnement
par gros temps on me disait zen même pas
peur en tout cas dans cet environnement
j'avais la possibilité d totalement
présent à ce moment d' équilibre je
voyais le premier 1 ne se défaire je
voyais une opportunité à rentrer j'étais
totalement présent totalement conscient
et puis il ya eu les études les études
un peu chahuté en tout cas à l'école
même très chahutées oui tout était dans
le contrôle c'était pas ma pratique de
l'art de la vie tout était dans le
contrôle dans la maîtrise puis j'ai j'ai
eu la chance malgré tout de faire des
études supérieures que j'ai réussi j'ai
fait celui polytechnique et puis des
études commerciales
un prétexte extraordinaire pour passer
mon temps évidemment à naviguer le
statut privilégié de l'étudiant entre
les entre les examens et les travaux
pratiques dès mon coéquipier et moi on a
même prolongé nos études
artificiellement pour rester dans le
circuit professionnel et un jour on
s'est dit on va transformer tout ça on
va transformer notre association
sportive céline team pour en faire une
société commerciale avec l'ambition de
comment vient de formuler sa monnaie
voilà on s'était dit nous allons
accompagner les équipes de direction des
grandes entreprises pour transformer
leur culture et changer l'économie pour
l'amener à + justesse du haut de nos 25
ans branche ofsaa chaussée fier nous
avons acheté dix bateaux 101 francs à
l'époque
non sans un euro en poche j'ai plus donc
901 francs en poche à l'époque et ça a
pris
nous naviguions beaucoup plus qu'à
beaucoup plus qu'avant toujours en
compétition à cette fois ci les
compétitions que nous organisions pour
nous mêmes pour nos clients qui en
général n'avait jamais jusqu'à de leur
vie pour nos décideurs alors la mise en
scène la mise en situation était plutôt
interpellante c'est évident et petit à
petit notre notre questionnement
après les navigations devenait de plus
en plus puissants
quinze ans plus tard 25 bateaux en
france en belgique en espagne près de
300 skipper qui encadrent nos décideurs
nos cadres en une dizaine de langues
qu'ils viennent d'une trentaine de pays
en tout ils seront cinquante mille à
embarquer 30 milles entre 2005 et 2007
dans le cadre de la de la très
prestigieuse america's cup
valencia réputation en béton position de
quasi monopole pas une dette
nous sommes vraiment les rois du monde à
ce moment là d'autant plus que en 2007
la coupe et et gagner à valencia et et
est annoncée pour trois ans encore là
bas c'est dire si la vie était été rose
et ça arrive en la crise financière de
2008 réduit notre chiffre d'affaires de
90 % en 2010 je dépose le bilan
nos clients est un ancien membre des
grandes entreprises financières des
grands consultant l'america's cup
s'embarque dans un arbre et guillaume un
broc glio juridique qui l'emmène au aux
états unis bref le château de cartes
s'effondre château de cartes s'effondre
et je me retrouve la dent dans une
situation où il ne reste plus grand
chose où je suis amené à faire face à
des aux émotions de mes collaborateurs
de la tristesse de la colère je vais en
fait être très endettés parce
qu'évidemment je mets beaucoup trop de
temps à déposer le bilan ma caution
personnelle est élevé bref il n'ya
d'autre solution que de retrouver de la
simplicité d'aller à l'essentiel
je suis plus souvent à la maison plus de
bureau plus de voyages plus de bateaux
il faut vivre il faut vivre avec
avec sous la rue myrha
celui ci sous base de la rémunération de
ma femme est et sur base de et avec
trois ados à la maison alors je reprends
cette posture
cette posture dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure du marin dans le baston même
pas peur même pas peur parce que au-delà
de l'émotion de la tristesse et il y a
en fait cette possibilité de totalement
présente alain d'être totalement présent
à ce moment de m'ouvrir devoir de rien
laissé se dégénérer autour de moi
surtout pas la relation avec avec avait
avait avec mes plus proches
évidemment et puis évidemment comme
toujours après le mauvais temps
l'éclaircie apparaît le monde s'ouvre il
va s'ouvrir dans un premier temps sur
base de quelque chose que j'avais voulu
faire depuis très très longtemps puisque
l'abondance du temps m'était donné je me
suis formé je me suis perfectionnée au
coaching et surtout je découvre la
spiritualité joyeuse dans un monastère
en syrie et je vous assure c'est
vraiment un concept pour moi étant
terriblement rebelles par rapport à mon
éducation judéo-chrétienne l'ouverture
le mot sur l'ouverture sur le monde se
présente je laisse venir à moi c'est
qu'il doit venir
je lâche prise je décide d'en faire
moins pour être plus
alors ce qui est intéressant ce qui
évidemment la précarité c'est que je
n'ai aucun moyen pour m'offrir tout cela
je n'ai qu'une seule stratégie c'est
évidemment me consacrer le plus possible
à ce que font les autres investir dans
le développement et dans la promotion de
leurs projets sans rien demander en
retour et tout me sera offert en retour
c'est absolument étonnant tous ces
programmes de formation vous seront
donnés tous ces projets me seront donnés
en fait je prends conscience qu'il est
vraiment temps de sortir de cette vision
cette vision linéaire du monde comme
s'il y avait un début il y avait une fin
que les choses qui devaient réussir
devait rater comme si ce monde et est
duale les choses sont blanches les
choses sont noirs alors certes certes ça
nous a permis pendant pendant deux
siècles de connaître une évolution de
notre intelligence technologiques à des
niveaux jamais connus mais à un prix à
un prix qui pour moi est une régression
fondamentale nous avons totalement perdu
notre capacité des trucs connectés être
connecté à soi d'abord tellement
challenge et par ce qui se passe autour
de nous d'être connecté aux autres
d'être connecté cet environnement que
j'ai pourtant énormément pratiquer et
d'être connecté surtout à ce qui nous
dépasse et qu'on ne nomme pas
je décide donc d'ouvrir de nouvelles
portes il ya le choix de la posture
regarder ces femmes il ya le choix de la
deûle et le choix de la bonne posture ya
le choix de la vraie création de
richesse celle qui consiste à vivre
ensemble pour développer notre humanité
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire ce que ça
veut dire pour moi c'est c'est rentrer
dans ce lâcher prise conscient de ce que
nous pouvons chacun de nous percevoir en
particulier en étendant cette confiance
d'appartenir à une cohérence à quelque
chose qui tient la route
autour autour de nous je vous parle
vraiment de cette possibilité de nous
reconnaître ce qui veut dire renaître
connectés la première question censée de
ma vie apparaît
qui suis-je pour faire ce que j'ai à
faire y at il une autre question
et cette question là qui va m'ouvrir ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'intelligence
spirituel au delà de l'intelligence
mentale au delà de l'intelligence
émotionnelle
au delà de l'intelligence physique
cette intelligence spirituel percevoir
que nous sommes chacun totalement unique
est une hypothèse assez intéressante et
assez facile à prendre
dans la mesure où attend que je n'ai pas
croisé mon clown au coin d'une rue je
peux croire que je suis une création
biologique totalement original donc
cette croyance de l'unicité du caractère
totalement unique de ma présence sur
terre
c'est un peu orgueilleux mais je passais
pragmatique en même temps
faire l'hypothèse percevoir que nous
faisons partie d'un tout n'est pas aussi
simple n'est pas aussi simple parce
qu'il s'agit de sortir de son enveloppe
et sommes-nous nombreux être capable à
l'invitation des bouddhistes de
pratiquer cet alignement qui nous
mènerait au bonheur cet alignement entre
notre psyché notre mental notre nos
émotions et notre corps quoi qu'il en
soit je pense que là au delà de notre
enveloppe je pense que c'est une des
plus grandes intuitions humaine sur
terre que nous faisons partie d'un tout
d'une cohérence de quelque chose qui
fait qu'on a peut vraiment émettre
l'hypothèse que nous appartenons un même
corps comme l'oreille et le nez font
partie du même visage mais ils n'ont pas
d'yeux pour se voir ils ne le savent pas
il faut un regard extérieur pour le pour
le découvrir l'humanité semble en effet
depuis bien longtemps totalement fasciné
par sa pratique de la nature par sa
pratique de par sa pratique de deux des
cycles de la vie bien au delà des
religions du réductionnisme des
réductions opérées par les religieuses
et les idéologies totalement fasciné par
pas parce tout par cette cohérence par
ce tout qui qui s'il est n'existe pas il
serait au delà de ce qui existe il
serait cette intelligence qui crée cette
cohérence totalement totalement
fascinante
alors je décide dans ma vie de pratiquer
ce que ce qui je croyais jusqu'à leur
avait été la cause de ma faillite le
papillonnage professionnels
cette totale disponibilité à ceux qui se
présentent à ce qu'il m'est offert la
première viendra d'un ami qui est patron
de la chambre de commerce la fédération
patronale de bruxelles l'équivalent
d'une c6 comme ici sauf que chez nous
c'est un modèle prise et c'est un modèle
public et et du medef les deux les deux
fusionner ou il me sera demandé de dans
l'équipe de direction de nourrir la
mission de cette organisation qui
consiste à accompagner les entrepreneurs
l'économie les entreprises à développer
une profonde richesse pour la société
ça ça me convient mais en tant
qu'indépendant le papillonnage devient
marguerite et ma disponibilité
j'aurai une autre belle invitation qui
ne sera fait un peu plus tard c'est
celle d'une fondation européenne
spécialisée dans l'innovation et dans
son financement qui invitera à sa
présidence
et puis et puis je vais m'ouvrir au
dialogue interconfessionnel
interconfessionnelles inter
convictionnels dont concluant les
spiritualités non religieuse et je me
retrouve et je me retrouve en juillet
dernier à doha au qatar invité pour la
première semaine du ramadhan où je suis
invité à m'associer aux prêches dans les
mosquées
cette terre en un concept pour moi avait
été approché pour développer une idée
qui m'a demandé il me demande qu'est ce
que tu vois quand tu nous regardes
c'est une première pour moi ça c'est
certain je n'ai pas de réponse je n'ai
que mon point de vue c'est une première
pour eux puisque je ne suis pas musulman
je découvre une abondance incroyable
leur profonde richesse leur profonde
spiritualité
au delà de tous les clichés dans un pays
dans un monde que j'avais éjecté de ma
carte du monde comme disait comme comme
disait comme disait aline qu'elle
abondance quelle richesse
ça voudrait dire que de la même manière
dans le coaching je me lance dans le
coaching ce que je me suis formé à ça
dès le moment où j'annonce ma
fascination total contre quelqu'un
de rentrer d'avoir ce privilège de
rentrer dans une cohérence totalement
originale dans une intelligence suprême
et complexe où je n'ai rien à conseiller
et j'ai juste en fait à tendre le miroir
je me dis c'est incroyable ce que cela
signifie pour moi le simple fait
dénoncer ma fascination pour le coaching
est ce que je reçois quand j'écoute
quelqu'un va faire que le coaching va
m'arriver tout seul les demandes tombe
cela voudrait dire que voir l'abondance
parler d'abondance génère est elle de
l'abondance est ce aussi simple que ça
c'est ma croyance
nous avons tous la possibilité que nous
soyons des entrepreneurs économiques
d'entrepreneurs sociaux des
entrepreneurs familiaux pour garder
cette image de tourner votre regard
on peut passer d'une perception de
limites
une perception de la finitude une
perception de la précarité
éventuellement à une perception de la
totale abondance qu'il ya dans cette
image
c'est vraiment un choix c'est ce qu'on
appelle se convertir
je ne parle pas de religion je parle de
l'étymologie de ce mot ça consiste à se
tourner ce regard en se connectant en se
connectant à soi en se connectant aux
autres en se connectant à cette
extraordinaire environnement que nous
comprenons à peine en se connectant
peut-être à ce tout qui n'existe pas et
qui serait au delà de ce qui existe
un homme m'a énormément influencé c'est
c'est jean yves leloup par hasard
anonyme puisque je m'appelle aussi le
loup est ce qu'il ya des hasards j'en
sais rien enfin bref c'est un diktat
cet homme nous invite nous invite
d'abord à expérimenter le plaisir de la
vie à nous connecter par le plaisir
offert par nos cinq sens lorsque nous
rentrons en contact avec ceux qui nous
entourent et puis nous dit au delà du
plaisir
il ya peut-être en fait le bonheur aller
chercher le bonheur c'est cet alignement
dont le bouddhiste nous parlait tout à
l'heure qui consiste tout simplement en
fait à aligner nos différents encore
notre psyché notre mental notre coeur
nos émotions et notre et notre physique
et puis elle troisième invitation au
delà du du plaisir
au delà du bonheur il y aurait la joie
et la joie c'est cette capacité que nous
avons à nous lever à nous mettre en
marche dans cette
dans ce total lâché prise dans cette
totale confiance en fait parce que on
partirait de l'hypothèse pour faire
partie d'un tout et puis il ya une
quatrième invitation mais cette 4e
invitation c'est au delà du plaisir au
delà du bonheur au-delà de cette joie il
y a cette possibilité que je n'ai pas
expérimenté de voir au bout du chemin
quelque chose c'est ce que les chrétiens
vont appeler la béatitude un mot que je
n'ai jamais compris la béatitude ou que
l'on pourrait aussi nommer simplement le
silence
vous rendez vous compte de cette posture
est prise de joie de flexibilité
d'agilité qui nous permet de rentrer
sans aucune barrière dans la totale
originalité de la pression qui se
présente à moi c'est juste une
libération totale extrêmement
fondamental or tout ce que je vous dis
tout ce que je vous ai dit ce n'est pas
vrai ce sont des croyances je pense et
je les lui je n'ai rien inventé
je pense que nous avons sept profond de
liberté de choisir nos croyances si je
crois que l'homme est bon je m'ouvre à
la rencontre
or je sais que des hommes sont dangereux
donc ce n'est pas vrai on hypothèse
n'est pas vrai et les très porteuse
al'inverse si je crois que l'homme est
mauvais je me ferme à la rencontre donc
ma profonde liberté elle est là c'est le
choix de mes croyances n'ayant pas accès
à la vérité
quoi qu'on en dise vous avez vu ces mots
il s'agit donc de renaître
il s'agit de nous reconnaître ça veut
dire de renaître connecter à autre chose
que notre petite enveloppe
il s'agit de nous convertir au sens je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure ça veut dire se
tourner en se connectant à ce qui est
plus large que que nous j'ai lu une
étude qui est absolument fascinante un
million sept employés dans 63 pays ont
été interviewés sur une question qui
était très simple est-ce que vous
utilisez vos talents vos points forts
dans votre engagement professionnel 20%
ont dit oui
merveilleux non qu'elle abonde ans c'est
à dire que sans investir un euro en plus
on a 80 % de croissance disponible sous
la main à condition de permettre aux
gens d'utiliser leur talent leur point
fort
ça c'est de l'abondance
voilà je voudrais conclure en vous
invitant à deux choses la première est
elle a été dit par cet homme qui nous a
un peu un peu d'appuis énormément de
place je pense dans nos vies qu'on le
veuille ou pas cette idée de se lever et
de marcher ça a été évoqué toute la
journée
lève toi et marche comme disait l'autre
dans cette connexion à soi dans cette
connexion à ses proches
et puis les autres dans cette connexion
cet environnement extrêmement
merveilleux qui nous entoure et puis
dans cette connexion à ce tout qui
n'existe pas qui est au delà de ce qui
existe et on a tellement de mal à
reconnaître je voudrais aussi vous
inviter à quelque chose qui me paraît
fondamental pour moi c'est puissions
nous puissions nous vraiment faire ce
que nous pensons pensée dans le respect
de qui nous sommes profondément être
dans la conscience de se plier et qui
n'existe pas
même pas peur
merci beaucoup